we got a gentleman right here who's
obviously interested and has a question
for us
i'm uh sugashan o'malley i got a
question
uh what do you think about six
nine huh i wanna know i wanna i wanna
know about
about your hair too i [ __ ] love you
i'm a fan i saw you talk about this
before but i'm a fan dude i think it's
almost
fascinating and i know the question for
you but uh but i just stole it but
um i think it's just the dude's
fascinating bro like when he said he was
gonna be on at midnight i [ __ ] showed
up i was there yeah
i was like i'm a fan too but then people
like oh he's just
i don't give a [ __ ] i don't pay
attention to who he snitched on what he
was in jail for i don't give a [ __ ]
i just think his music's hype we're
going to the gym
or we're [ __ ] we're we're getting
hyped i'm throwing on some six nine
gooba
yeah and if i gotta watch the music
video with nicki minaj
watch that a couple times already you
see that yeah yeah i saw it twice dude
it was tatas but yeah
i'm a fan of his k he's a character yes
that is
his character is working and about the
hair before
we even knew six nine like my debut did
we talked about hey let's do my hair
like
like crazy and i kind of wanted to
establish my name in ufc get it
you know show that i'm for real and then
uh so so the hair
was definitely a little bit inspired by
like dude that his hair looks sick it
looks [ __ ] cool and he's crazy yeah
and he's a [ __ ]
character i want to be a character i
want people to be like what the if
they've never seen fighting
i want them to look at the screen like
what the f i want to watch this guy
right you got crazy areas tall as [ __ ]
skinny
well you have to stand out especially if
you want to i mean
it's interesting to watch what you guys
do in y'all's business like it's
definitely changed over the past few
years i think with guys calling each
other out more
like becoming characters like everything
in the world has kind of become
you know we talk about it a lot that
everything's kind of become like the wwe
a little bit
like every like politicians everybody
it's all about just sound bites and how
can i how can i rise out of whatever's
going on
and and be seen really absolutely yeah
and it definitely seems like you do that
do you think you'll have a different
hairstyle like
do you have other plans for like uh for
future bounce yeah i think we're going
to continue with the like doings
different colors my hair
danny my girl does hair so she did all
this so and she we got a bunch of
different colors so we'll play around
with it um
maybe i was thinking like uh whoever i
fight next wearing their flag color hair
oh that'd be dope just to peck at him
like when i fought jose
i like to say things that are gonna
nudge at him when i thought jose i said
we'll see who's more mexican yeah and he
got pissed
but then i get people saying you're
racist like my girl's [ __ ] mexican
yeah
but just saying little things that are
gonna fire people up because if i can
get someone emotional to fight me
right they're gonna come forward like
jose did they're gonna come forward like
eddie didn't want to take my head off
and that's not a good game plan you're
getting knocked out doing that so if i
can get someone emotional and wanna
really just hit me that's good because
do you respond like say if somebody did
that to you
you don't respond to it the same way i
don't take anything personally right
like i know i understand that you could
say i [ __ ] your mom a bit
cool like you'd tell somebody but my mom
yeah my mom [ __ ] at least probably
five people everybody's mom did yeah
exactly
but just not taking anything personally
right and yeah cause it's interesting
because she's so that's what okay so to
you it's like
it's a game it's a gets a show it's a
show it's a [ __ ] it's suga
yeah but i'm i'm sean in a way where i'm
always kind of shunned but i'm not going
to take it personally right
it's going to be if i take it personally
that's going to affect how i fight i
might fight emotional right and when i
don't fight emotions i fight calm
yeah very calm and i feel like the more
calm i can be the more dangerous i am so
if someone says something and
i get personal about it i think it could
change how i fight it definitely changes
how people fight me
oh for sure well it's how most fights
start like if you're just in regular
human interaction like at a bar or post
office or whatever most people fight
because somebody gets [ __ ] pissed
emotional and guys like cody garbrandt
who get mad if you sneeze next to him
yeah he's like holy [ __ ] that's too easy
yeah like i'm sure he's already just at
home jonah
good afternoon and other times thanks
for watching that video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah